aujourd'hui on se parle de ça ça c'est
le macbook des seize le tout nouveau pc
portable de huawei est la première chose
à savoir c'est 899 euros
c'est un fait c'est qui est abordable
alors 899 euros c'est une somme ça reste
beaucoup d'argent mais pour pc portable
vous assurer que c'est vraiment
intéressant lorsqu'on va faire
aujourd'hui on va seul ouvriront le seul
boxeur roumain regarder tout ça on va
regarder si pour 899 euros vous en avez
pour votre argent avec ce même groupe d
on va regarder ou est-ce qu'il se situe
dans la gamme de huawei et qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire avec
[Musique]
toutes premières sont bien évidemment on
a quoi ça ça c'est un bloc de chien je
monte en max à 20 volts 3,25 en perse et
un chargeur 65 watts donc là c'est pour
faire écho à la vidéo que je vous ai
l'autre jour sur les chargeurs usb csbc
ça me paraît complètement normal
la machine en elle même c'est pas mal
première chose comme ça j'aime bien
l'aspect esthétique ya vraiment un côté
premium il ya une seule couleur ici une
seule couleur un seul modèle une seule
configuration je vous détaille tout ça à
la fin la couleur c'est le space grèce
je le trouve assez fin c'est du 16
pouces donc forcément voyez on n'est pas
sur une bête mini mini mini ici j'ai
deux ports usb c'est qui me serviront
tous les deux pour la charge j'ai ici un
port hdmi d'oxygène aux branches un
moniteur externe c'est plutôt pas mal
si j'ai deux ports usb à 3.2 une prise
jack 3.5
on attendait j'ouvre sa toque hockey à
sagem bien d'ailleurs surtout que je
suis super super premium c'est l'aspect
global que vous avez ici on retrouve un
trackpad qui est suffisamment grand les
haut parleurs stéréo sur le côté apporte
vraiment en expérience et ça c'est très
très sympa le touch est super agréable
la course n'est pas trop longue en
termes de frappe c'est vraiment
intéressant alors ce que vous retrouvez
vous l'avez chihuahua gaza c'est
vraiment un truc qu'ils ont mis en avant
depuis quelques années c'est la webcam
qui est planqué ici dans une touche pour
les questions de confidentialité
alors moi je suis pas très fan de ça
pourquoi parce qu'en fait ça vous fait
une espèce de contre-plongée ou envoi
sous votre meilleur mais je n'ai vous
parlez de vos amis comme ça on va tous
les poils sous votre nez c'est
intéressant d'une parce que ça vous
permet effectivement de gagner sur la
finesse ans au niveau de l'écran de
votre ordinateur pour pas perdre deux
places bien qu'encore aujourd'hui les
marques arrivent à miniaturiser ça donc
ça aurait pu le faire qui connaissant le
travail de en r&d de huawei aurait pu
faire mais ils ont préféré le mettre
dans le clavier
bon c'est un choix pourquoi pas demandez
pas si vous trouvez ça vous intéressant
en bas en commentaire d'un point de vue
purement esthétique moi j'aime bien le
clavier je trouve premium
on a bien toutes ces touches fonctions
qui sont situées sur le haut d'un bouton
aussi que ce capteur d'empreintes
digitales
on n'est pas sur une machine très très
très très performant temps des essais
marqués vous le voyez juste ici on est
sur amd auditionnera zone 5
c'est la série 4000 mots qu'est ce qu'on
va venir faire ici avec une machine avec
cette configuration là eh bien on va
dire faire de la bureautique bureautique
familiale bureautique professionnelle
tout ce qui va être télétravail ça
aujourd'hui télétravail on en a des
caisses tout ce qui va être
plus familial venir regarder des films
des séries son envie de se faire dans
des deux fixes le soir dans le lit et
bien on peut on met l'ordinateur avec
nous et il n'y a pas de souci ça
fonctionnera bien nous tous qui va être
divertissement familial aussi petit
gaming vraiment pas dégeu performant
vraiment pas des jeux qui vont demander
de la ressource on est vraiment sûr du
petit gaming ici quelques petits jeux un
peu rigolo mais pas plus vous pourrez
faire tourner une suite adobe photoshop
s'en mettent des centaines de calques
vous mettez quelques petits call vous
pourrez faire mais au delà ça ne
fonctionnera plus l'idée c'est la
machine polyvalent pour la famille un
prix intéressant et surtout avec un
écran 16 pouces premier truc qui va être
sympa ici c'est le capteur d'empreintes
digitales ans je sais pas si vous le
savez mais avec windows 10 de microsoft
vous avez la possibilité de venir
sécuriser votre ordinateur de
déverrouiller grâce à windows et l'eau
pour déverrouiller votre ordinateur vous
avez plusieurs possibilités soit vous
tapez un mot de passe c'est fastidieux
soit vous avez votre caméra qui
reconnaît votre visage windows et l'eau
c'est bien c'est pratique mais à la
caméra est embarqué en bas donc ici il
faudrait venir appuyer le vais regarder
appuyé non c'est fastidieux ici ce qui
nous en fait c'est tout simplement un
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui est
situé ici regardez là je vous mets en
plan large quand vous voyez je pose mon
doigt il déverrouille directement ça va
très vite
nova c'est sympa alors il ya quelques
points négatifs bien évidemment elle va
faire tourner des applis extrêmement
gourmand tu les programmes qui demande
beaucoup de ressources ici et bien vous
allez devoir passer votre chemin ce
n'est pas cette machine qui vous faudra
ici par contre elle est vraiment hyper
hyper agréable sur un grand écran comme
ça marche ça j'aime beaucoup ça vraiment
très très cool
j'adore les ordinateurs des écrans 16
pouces on va être dans l'idée d'un grand
châssis d'un 15 pouces avec un écran 16
pouces que vous allez me reloger ici
c'est justement ce que vient rajouter
cet ordinateur dans cette gamme de
huawei des macbook parce que dans les
mails book de huawei vous aviez déjà le
des 14 plus petit petit écran plus
compact qu'on va emmener partout
facilement avec soi dans une sacoche on
comprendra le macbook des 15 pareil la
même idée mais un poil plus grand entre
le 14 et le 16 et il manquait
effectivement de configuration un peu
plus grande avec ce 16 pouces là alors
ce ces secousses là il est sympa mais
vous n'allez pas l'emmener partout avec
vous on n'est plus aux ordinateurs
portables sédentaires familiale à la
différence de l'ordinateur de bureau
vous allez poser un endroit chez vous
n'allez pas bougé fatalement c'est un
petit peu compliqué de dire des brochets
la tour bouge et l'écran et compagnie
celui là vous allez laisser chez vous
vous pouvez leur dire si vous souhaitez
vous pouvez mais il est quand même un
petit peu plus grand globalement il va
rester à l'intérieur de votre domicile
par contre il va venir changer d'endroit
il vous servira aussi bien pour du
télétravail lorsque vous avez besoin de
vous
donner dans un bureau donc ça il ya un
côté très pratique on vient le déplacer
il n'est pas très lourd
franchement effet moins de 2 kg je crois
qu'on est un kilo 707 machine en fait
voir des bras là je suis un peu de muscu
kg 7 1 kg 600 900 kg 7 à quelque chose
près donc on est sur une machine qu'on
va déplacer très facilement chez soi
donc ça c'est extrêmement pratique mais
qu'on ne va pas emmener partout en
déplacement on peut mais c'est pas
forcément l'adn de cette machine là
alors les limites je voulais montrent
tout de suite je gardais là par exemple
je vais me remettre une petite vidéo ici
je me mets tenez regardez moi non teaser
sur ma chaîne youtube je pense que vous
allez vous en rendre compte
je vous fait écouter comme ça a lâché au
tac aux 60% écoutez ça voyez enfin et
c'est le son est médium ici on n'arrive
pas à avoir un son qui va être enrichie
avec des graves et même lorsqu en baisse
on reste vraiment sera son médium donc
les haut parleurs sont pas complètement
dingue ou dingo d'un autre côté je vous
le remet une fois de plus 899 euros pour
pour regarder des films ce que je viens
vous conseille ici de vous connecter en
bluetooth parce que oui si peu vous
connecte en bluetooth facilement et ça
c'est bien ou d'utiliser votre prise
jack de brancher un casque ça maximisera
l'expérience à côté de ça la dalle est
suffisamment lumineuse des joues plus la
luminosité à fond
vous n'allez pas vous mettre sur une
terrasse en plein soleil moment ça va
cogner de plus ça va forcément arriver
un moment où vous allez être limité mais
pour travailler en intérieur y aura
absolument aucun problème et ça c'est
parfait ici au niveau de l'écran 16 9ème
vous êtes sur un full hd à 137 pays
116,1 pouces écrans full diouf view
c'est une référence
huawei 100% srgb avec un taux
d'occupation de 90 % au niveau du ratio
châssis écran alors ici c'est pas du
tout un écran tactile c'est pas non plus
qu'on vient chercher ici en plus à 800 à
plat celui-ci à 899 euros
mais malgré tout mais malgré tout c'est
un écran qui est certifié lutter contre
la lumière bleue pour venir protéger vos
évitez que vous fassiez mal le soir ou
la journée lorsque vous passez beaucoup
d'heures dessus parce qu'on sait qu'on
passe beaucoup dans le sud et l'est
travail films séries pour se détendre le
soir arrive un moment où forcément les
yeux il n'aime pas trop ici pas de souci
donc ça c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle
néanmoins faites quand même attention
attention aux usages excessifs attention
à bien régler ça c'est vraiment
important à bien régler la luminosité de
votre écran par rapport à l'éclairage
ambiant
même si c'est un écran qui certifie
lutter contre la lumière bleue si vous
mettez luminosité trop forte sur votre
écran et une très faible luminosité dans
votre pièce vous risquez un moment et
bien de vous faire un peu mal
c'est vraiment adapté ici la luminosité
de votre écran pour vous ayez un confort
de lecture qu'il soit suffisamment bon
sans forcément mettre trop important moi
ce que j'aime bien ici c'est les
finitions en alu brossé extrêmement
premium un autre point positif on n'y
pense pas forcément c'est qu'ici vous
avez une dalle qui est bat ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que là j'ai une sorte box
qui est assez énorme
alors si jamais comme ça forcément ça
risque de faire un petit peu mal aux
yeux mais ça ne réfléchit pas regarder
on voit pas la caméra par exemple oui il
refait de la caméra vous ne voyez pas
moi je ne vois pas je vais vraiment
baisser la luminosité à fond pour vous
puissiez vous en rendre compte
et est ce que vous voyez le reflet de la
caméra que dalle ici c'est vraiment
l'intérêt d'avoir une une dalle comme
samat ce qui fait que si vous avez un
peu trop de lumière et bien vous n'allez
pas vous voir il ya passé fait miroir
dans l'écran donc ça c'est sympa ici
vous avez refroidissement avec deux
ventilateurs vous les voyez vous en avez
un ici vous avez le deuxième qui est
situé juste ici ventilateur avec des
pales plus fine plus nombreux et surtout
qui ne font pas de bruit
on est en dessous de 35 décibels autre
point intéressant ici vous avez du wifi
6-1 windows dix familles une batterie de
55 watts heure huawei nous annonce une
autonomie de 9,5 heures en lecture de
vidéo et elle existe en une seule
configuration amd risers 5 16 giga de
ram et 512 giga de stockage et au tarif
2 et je vous leur montre une fois de
plus
899 euros d'ailleurs si elle vous
intéresse je vous ai bien ligue 1 en bas
dans la description il ya un autre point
qui est très intéressant avec l'univers
de wow c'est l'interconnexion des
appareils ici g
montez 40 pro ici j'ai mon ordinateur
jusque là rien de bien compliqué eh bien
il ya une solution qui s'appelle ou wes
sherwood cher j'en avais déjà pas
l'année dernière j'avais déjà fait une
vidéo
c'est le fait de faire communiquer ces
appareils entre je voulais montrer
l'autre jour sur la voie royale si par
exemple j'écoute de la musique ici sur
mon smartphone
voyez c'est julie coin sur le smartphone
et je veux bien transférer directement
je vais la poser directement leurs aînés
c'est up et c'est de connecter
directement ici
la musique vient plus de là la musique
vient directement dans l'enceinte est en
fait c'est exactement la même chose ici
à savoir que fut une époque l'année
dernière notamment vous avait déjà
présenté avec huawei ils avaient sur
leurs ordinateurs ici d'un petit endroit
marqué huawei cher donc là où il y avait
la puce nfc sources connectées ici grâce
au nfc
vous vous posiez autres smartphones qui
se connectent et sauf que plein de
personnes en fait veulent avoir un
ordinateur sans aucune autocollant est
supprimée et donc du coup ici ça
fonctionnait plus du tout donc qu'est-ce
qui se passe ils vous ont mis la puce
nfc dans le trackpad donc quand vous
arrivez avec votre smartphone la voyez
il n'est pas connectée je le prends au
plat je le pose à [ __ ] ou le bon
endroit
voilà je me décale j'ai la vibration est
ici à regarder il se connecte
directement alors hop là j'ai déjà fait
l'autorisation sinon ils vous demandent
une autorisation pour se connecter d'un
côté lot mais moi j'ai déjà fait et bien
quand je décale sur le smartphone ça
décale sur l'écran en fait ça me fait du
mirroring aller plus ni moins ce qui
fait que je peux venir travailler sur
mon ordinateur avec un programme un
logiciel est en train de télétravail et
avoir mon smartphone ici pour pouvoir
envoyer des messages dont vous pouvez
bosser ici avec deux programmes au
niveau de votre ordinateur un programme
à gauche à programme à droite vous
imaginez que vous travaillez d'un côté
côté vous avez lancé rien vos emails et
bien là dessus et si vous pouvez avoir
d'autres contacts avec qui vous parle
est pourquoi pas des contacts sein des
lions allez savoir faites ce que vous
voulez donc l'idéal est super
intéressante donc ça déjà c'est
vachement bien dans ce sens là et en
plus c'est super intéressant pour venir
partager des choses on va faire une
photo un soir une photo un peu à la
hache
je venais comme ça avec l'appareil on
regarde voilà on fait une photo j'ai
donc ma photo qui est là et ma photo
eh bien elle est là mais en fait je
voudrais qu'elle est carrément
d'ordinateurs je veux pas juste avoir du
mirroring mais je te l'envoie une
ordinateur
qu'est ce que je fais je pose ici tac et
je vais envoyer directement ma photo
dans mon ordinateur je viens ensuite
dans mon application pc managers qui se
trouve juste là donc là je peux venir
tout paramétrer la collaboration multi
écrans les photos et compagnie et là
regardez ici je récupère dire
comment les photos notamment aux plats
voyez celle là que je n'en voyais donc
ma photo est parti dans mon ordinateur
c'est donc extrêmement pratique pour
venir partager des photos pour nous dire
partager des vidéos pour venir partager
des documents jeu pranger pause je
connecte fait du mirroring peut
travailler avec deux programmes ouvert
son ordinateur et en plus
et bien j'en ai une autre grâce à ce que
je vois sur mon smartphone en retard de
productivité cb en termes de partage
familial c'est bien on voit beaucoup
d'usagers arrière et moi en tout cas
huawei cherche trouve ça intéressant et
c'est une partie intégrante de leur
écosystème pour venir faire communiquer
les appareils entre eux donc moi j'aime
bien dites moi vous maintenant ce que
vous en pensez en bas aux commentaires
comment vous trouvez cette machine est
ce qu'elle vous intéresse qu elle
pourrait vous intéresser à ce que vous
avez déjà un ordinateur portable de
huawei est ce que huawei chef c'est
aussi une solution qui vous intéresse
alors moins cher ça marche bien
évidemment avec un smartphone de huawei
marqué le moins bien évidemment en bas
en commentaire quant à elle on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler texte sans avoir beaucoup d'amour
pour les soigner et à très bientôt
ciao